another new switch model is being
reported
cyberpunk 2077 will have free dlc and
adjustable subtitles and dc fandom
confirmed two new games headed our way
gotham knights and suicide squad i'm
persia and you've reached your safe
state for monday
august 24th
[Music]
a new and improved version of the
nintendo switch is being reported again
and according to economic daily news it
could be here as early as the first few
months of 2021. economic daily news
cites manufacturing sources in its
report because manufacturers would need
to know ahead of time
in order to get the console ready for
sale by the projected date
as far as what improvements the new
switch could have the report only
mentions a better display
and enhanced interactivity details may
be vague but this isn't the first report
or a rumor we've heard about an improved
switch model coming soon
since in the past wall street journal
claimed we'd see a more powerful switch
and a cheaper version in the future with
the second one turning out to be true
with the switch light
no word yet on if this improved model
will adjust anything like storage or joy
cons but what's something you'd like to
see in the new switch
like the witcher 3 before it cd project
red has confirmed on twitter that
cyberpunk 2077 will offer free dlc after
launch and you'll even be able to adjust
the size and color
of the subtitles on day one cd projekt
red has previously told us here at
gamespot that the free
dlc with paid expansion model for the
witcher 3
worked really well and it didn't see why
it wouldn't try to replicate the same
model with cyberpunk 2077. there's been
no word yet
on any expansions though paid or not but
aside from dlc
cyberpunk 2077 will also offer extensive
accessibility options
including how your subtitles will look
another confirmation on twitter tells us
that changing the size and color of the
subtitles will be an option from the
start after
there was some initial worry from fans
when a screenshot from the official
account
sparked the discussion cd projekt red
has previously talked about the
importance of diversity and inclusion
within their games and
it looks like it even extends all the
way to accessibility options like
subtitles
i'm actually kind of curious to see how
big you can make the text
we got not one but two game
announcements out of dc
fandom gotham knights and suicide squad
kill the justice league
and despite what your first reaction may
tell you only one of these
is set in the arkham universe after a
string of rumors and teasers
wb montreal officially revealed its new
co-op action game
gotham knights you can play as robin
nightwing batgirl
or red hood who all have their own
distinct fighting styles
and since this title is not continuing
the story of the arkham games
you're fighting in a gotham where batman
is dead this also explains why we see
barbara gordon able to continue her
fight
as she was paralyzed in the arkham verse
however rocksteady's newly announced
suicide squad killed the justice league
will be set in the arkham verse
but since it's after arkham knight we
may not see certain villains make an
appearance
but who knows that could always change
suicide squad will also be a co-op
action game where you can play as harley
quinn
deadshot king shark and captain
boomerang and have to
reluctantly take down superman after he
kills an innocent civilian
gotham knights is set to release next
year for pc
current and next-gen consoles but it
seems as though we'll have to wait until
2022 for suicide squad
so no direct sequels to the arkham games
just yet but we'll definitely have some
games to dive into until that time comes
that's all for now but keep in mind that
we have about one week
left until our play for all donation
drive will come to an end
there's still a little bit of time to
get some merch and donate to black lives
matter and coveted 19 relief efforts
thank you so much for watching give me a
follow on twitter at persia underscore
xo
and of course have an amazing monday
we'll see you tomorrow for your next
safe state
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you